Ezequiel 75 años después de esta
resolución el secretario general de
Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
mantiene el discurso de los dos estados
una medida defendida públicamente en
varias ocasiones también por Joe biden
si bien públicamente no haya ningún
proceso de diálogos abierto considera
posible todavía la creación de un estado
palestino
a ver yo creo que en el deseo de los
palestinos está todavía la idea de crear
un estado palestino ahora en la práctica
o en el terreno la idea de crear un
estado un estado contigo palestino
Realmente es casi imposible es decir el
territorio de si Jordania donde prevé un
estado palestino junto a la franja de
gas el territorio está de alguna manera
perforado como un queso gruyere con
cerca de 160 asentamientos legales es
decir que el estado Israel los reconoce
y otros 100 asentamientos ilegales como
es un punto interesante pensar que el
nuevo líder de extrema derecha que
participa en la nueva colección israelí
es habitante uno asentamientos yo creo
que en Israel lo que está pasando Es que
año año los ciudadanos israelíes los
deberes de israelíes votan a candidatos
que no están a favor de los estados
y precisamente no está ocupación ilegal
de territorios palestinos el bloqueo de
gaza es denunciado tanto por Naciones
Unidas como por ongs internacionales
porque la comunidad internacional no
impone sanciones e incluso ciertos
países como Estados Unidos apoyan a
militarmente económicamente a Israel
creo que es complicado Yo creo que es
verdad mucha gente marca como una
especie de doble moral del mundo con
respecto al conflicto Israel y palestino
y nombran que por ejemplo el mundo está
Unido contra la ocupación rusa de
Ucrania pero no así con la
contracupación que ya llega más de medio
siglo y raíz sobre si Jordania es
complicado yo creo que
gran parte de lo que se denomina las
bará israelí lo que es parte de lo que
es relaciones públicas israelíes o
propaganda israelí asocia el conflicto a
una especie de odio milenario de los
áreas de los judíos cuando especialmente
es un conflicto territorial Yo creo que
esa idea esa idea de propaganda ha
penetrado por otro lado también me
gustaría decir que hasta el día de hoy a
pesar de que Estados Unidos no ha
demostrado haber sido un mediador justo
porque siempre ha inclinado un poco la
balanza hacia el lado israelí este el
único mediador que de alguna manera
puede convencer su realidad de hacer
algo es decir muchas veces se dice que
Estados Unidos tiene que salir del papel
porque no es justo porque tira más para
el lado israelí que para el lado
palestino pero lo interesante es pensar
que si entraría otro mediador como Rusia
como china directamente no tendrían
ninguna posibilidad de presionarlos y
realidades y precisamente crea que en lo
que queda de administración vaiden puede
haber algún Avance en algunos diálogos
no son para nada optimistas yo creo que
lo que se está discutiendo en este
momento en la administración biden Es
tratar que cuál es tu nuevo gobierno
israelí es tratar de que no entres en
llamas es decir que el territorio no
entren llamas en lo que se está
discutiendo en este momento en las
habitaciones vaiden es tratar de que
este nuevo gobierno donde un componente
fuerte es la extrema derecha israelí un
extrema derecha y Rally que si no
piensas acerca de 30 años había sido
expulsado del parlamento es decir lo que
trata de hacer es que no entren fuego al
territorio y aparece que el punto clave
para pensarlo que no tiene que entrar en
fuego es Jerusalén el tema es que
Jerusalén no se vaya de las manos